[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANANT SHUKLA: A James Beard
Award-winning pastry chef,
Dominique Ansel, has
shaken up the pastry
world with innovation
and creativity
at the heart of his work.
Named the World's Best Pastry
Chef in 2017 by the World's 50
Best Restaurants Awards, one
of "Business Insider's" most
innovative people under 40,
and Crain's 40 under 40,
Chef Dominique has
strived through his career
to bring a refreshing approach
to the world of desserts.
In 2015, he was bestowed the
prestigious 'Ordre du Merite
Agricole Award for
his accomplishments.
"Vanity Fair" named him one of
the 50 most influential French,
and "Daily Mail UK" claimed
he was the most feted pastry
chef in the world.
Prior to opening his
own shop, Dominique
served as the executive pastry
chef for the restaurant Daniel
here in New York City.
During his six years
there, he was instrumental
and was not only the longest
tenured pastry chef there,
he was a contributing
member to the team
that helped it earn its
coveted third Michelin
star and a four star review
in the New York Times.
As you saw, the
maker and creator
of such great and
wonderful desserts, he
known not only across
the world for his Cronut
but for all these other amazing
and delicious creations.
So please join me in welcoming
Chef Dominique back to Google
here.
[APPLAUSE]
DOMINIQUE ANSEL: Thank you.
ANANT SHUKLA: Welcome.
So Chef, welcome to Google.
DOMINIQUE ANSEL: Thank you.
ANANT SHUKLA: Is this
your first time here?
DOMINIQUE ANSEL: My first
time in this building.
ANANT SHUKLA: In this building,
what do you think so far?
DOMINIQUE ANSEL: It looks nice.
ANANT SHUKLA: It looks nice.
DOMINIQUE ANSEL: You guys
have nice offices here.
ANANT SHUKLA: Yeah.
But we're really excited
to have you here.
I kind of--
DOMINIQUE ANSEL: I was told
that I should see the cafeteria.
ANANT SHUKLA: Yes.
DOMINIQUE ANSEL: That
you guys are very lucky.
So I will check it
out before I leave.
ANANT SHUKLA: Yes.
So pretty, in a relatively
short amount of time,
you've become a world
renowned chef and pastry
chef recently recognized on
April 2017 as the World's Best
Pastry Chef.
Kind of let's start
with your journey
and how you decided this
was your profession that you
want to pursue.
What was that
inspiration and spark
that decided pastries
and desserts are
the way I'm going to head?
DOMINIQUE ANSEL: Well,
I didn't really decide.
I think life put me
through that track.
I grew up in a small
town North of Paris.
My dad was working in factories.
So we didn't have
much money growing up.
And to me finding a job was
a priority when I was young.
So I started
actually very early.
I was barely 16, I started
working in kitchen.
And I had no clue
what I was doing.
I had no idea what
was coming for me.
I actually hated it
in the first year.
I didn't like it at all.
I met some good people
in this industry that
taught me how to love my job.
I started working my way up.
Eventually I got
to Paris, where I
landed a job at Fauchon
which is one of the most well
known pastry shop.
And I worked my way up
there until I got here.
ANANT SHUKLA: Yeah.
So in the world, especially
where formal culinary training
is often a prerequisite, and
as you said you kind of just
decided and fell into
this, what was most
difficult about that journey?
Where you're expected to
kind of make the same cookie
as everybody else in
the production line,
or make the pastry the exact
same way, and obviously
innovation and creativity
fuels everything you've done.
What was most
challenging about that?
DOMINIQUE ANSEL: I
think, well, there's
a lot of things that
are very challenging.
The food industry
is a tough one.
You stand on your feet for
16 sometimes 18 hours a day.
You work weekends.
You don't see your friends.
You don't see your family.
You feel like living
almost like an offset life
compared to the normal people.
And it's a tough one because
there's a lot of competition.
It's very challenging.
And I think that
the most challenging
was, for me early on,
to find my passion
and to have all the stamina and
the dedication to put into it
is this life.
Because I'll never describe it
as a job, more as a lifestyle.
You have to love it.
And you have to live with it.
ANANT SHUKLA: Yeah.
And then making that jump
then from France to the US
was a large one, right?
DOMINIQUE ANSEL: Yes, it
was pretty big for me.
I had a pretty comfy job.
I was working one of the most
influential and renowned pastry
shop in Paris at the time.
I was the corporate pastry
chef developing shops
around the world.
And it was a comfortable
situation for me.
And I got a call from
Daniel Boulud asking me
if I wanted to join the team.
And at the time, you
know, my English was OK.
It was like not--
actually, it was not OK.
It was not good.
I shouldn't lie.
But you know, I came
here with two suitcases.
It was 10 years ago
now, working for Daniel.
And the same, I
started everything
all over again-- a new
country, new kitchen,
a new way of working.
And I've learned and I've
grown with everything
that was coming my way.
So it was very challenging,
not easy to adapt
from a different culture,
different country,
different kitchen,
different way of working.
But it was it an
amazing experience.
ANANT SHUKLA: Yeah.
As they say, the
New York City dream
of moving here and
building everything up.
I mentioned earlier,
that you were
part of that team that helped
it get the three Michelin star
rating.
What was the biggest learning
from that experience?
You mentioned you have to
work closely with Daniel.
It's a traditional kind of
French cuisine restaurant.
But you're trying to innovate.
You're trying to be creative.
How did you go about?
DOMINIQUE ANSEL:
Well, in the beginning
it was a little tricky
because I didn't
have that much
restaurant experience.
I only had like two years
in the past as a chef,
as a savory chef as well.
So working in a restaurant
was a little bit new for me.
I was working more
for like a bakery
and retail back in France.
So working in a
restaurant was new for me.
And working with
Daniel was new as well,
at this level of expectation.
And I had to find my style
and adapt in the kitchen,
working with the people
that were there as well
without the volume as well.
It's not like in France
where you have like,
you seat like 50, 60 people
and that's it for the day.
It's more like larger scale.
It's bigger spaces.
And high expectations as well.
So I found my style,
and practiced a lot
on the kind of pastry
I wanted to do.
Early on, I wanted to
do something different.
I didn't want to
just do classics.
I wanted something more
innovative and creative
when it comes to flavorous
presentations, and thinking
of pastry at a different level.
ANANT SHUKLA: Yeah.
And you mentioned Daniel was
not only kind of a mentor
but also a friend.
He wrote the foreword
to your cookbook.
How has that relationship
evolved, and like
you said, very
high expectations.
DOMINIQUE ANSEL: Yeah, it's a
very, very close relationship.
And it's almost like
if my American father,
even though he's French.
He's my American father.
He's grown him.
He's talked me.
He has supported me.
I always tell the
story and I always
remember that when
I told him that I
was going to leave Daniel
to open my own shop,
it was like telling your
girlfriend you were breaking up
with her.
He was not happy at all.
It like took him some
time to like to digest.
I remember I was sitting--
we were on the phone
for like a good like
an hour and a half.
And I had to like calm
him down, tell him
that I will keep the team
together, that everything will
be good, that I was not going
to work with anyone else,
that I was opening my own shop.
And he finally realized
and he's been like nothing
but supportive since then.
ANANT SHUKLA: Yeah.
So then when you're
in the kitchen
and you're, like I said, not
really a classically trained
mind set you're using,
but instead available
ingredients, combinations that
people aren't willing to try.
How do you get that
inspiration then
from what you're going to
try for the dessert or--
DOMINIQUE ANSEL: Well,
to me, it's always been--
I have always been curious my
entire life, since I was a kid.
Always been curious
about traveling,
about learning about different
cultures, about meeting people,
always been curious
about seeing what's
out there, and not just
what you see with just
staying in the kitchen.
So opening my mind was very
important for me, and not just
with food either.
I think that getting
inspiration from a lot
of different industries
and different parts of what
this world has to offer
has been important.
You know, I think
any creative person
is very curious of anything
and everything, pretty much.
I often check on
Instagram, for instance.
A few years ago, I was
looking at nail art.
I don't paint my nails, but
their art is very interesting
because they use
different tools,
they use different techniques.
And that got me inspired for
like new techniques for cake
glazing, for instance.
I've been looking
lately at pottery art.
So you know when
people do something
very cool like [INAUDIBLE],,
different techniques of using
clay.
And we actually have a
pottery wheel in the kitchen.
We do some piping and some
cool chocolate decor with it.
So I always look
what's out there.
And have also like
connection between the food
and the people.
So this is one of the most
important things for me.
You cannot just serve
food because it's good.
It has to have a
meaning, to have a story,
and to have a
connection with people.
The biggest example I can
give, it's the frozen s'mores.
So 10 years ago,
believe me or not,
I had no idea what a s'mores
was, before coming here.
And I've learned about it.
I've tasted it.
I've talked about it a lot.
And a few years ago, just
after we launched the Cronot,
we created the frozen s'mores.
So it's an ice cream version
of a s'more, and something that
was completely--
I was unaware that even
existed 10 years ago.
So it's essentially
a vanilla ice cream
that is coated with
a chocolate wafer
and pushed inside a
honey marshmallow.
So it looks like a cube.
We set it on a branch.
And the branch,
the wooden branch,
has been smoked with applewood,
and we torch the marshmallow
to order.
So you have this thin shell,
like caramelized shell
on the outside of
the marshmallow.
So when you bite
into, it's crunchy.
It's warm.
It's cold in the center.
It's chewy.
And you have all
this fun texture.
So it's like almost like
rediscovering the s'mores.
And that this is not even the
most beautiful part for me.
We opened a shop in
Tokyo a little bit
more than two years ago.
We brought the frozen
s'mores to Tokyo.
And of course, Japanese people
don't know what a s'more is
either.
And believe me or not, it
is one of our best sellers.
We sell close to 800 daily.
And it's something
that is amazing to me
that me a French person,
I can come here to America
and bring such a
classic American classic
to different country and
introduce it so people actually
love it.
ANANT SHUKLA: Yeah, I
think a similar story you
kind of talk about in the book
is around a chocolate chip
cookie as well.
Right?
And I know we'll talk about
the cookie shot later,
but I found it a very compelling
story about how you just
couldn't find a good cookie.
DOMINIQUE ANSEL: That's right.
I mean, French people
are amazing bakers.
Probably maybe the best in
the world, I have to say.
But they really
can't bake a cookie.
It's like unknown
in French culture.
They don't know what
a good cookie is.
They don't know how to bake it.
They don't know how to make it.
And they just don't eat it.
So my first great
cookie was here.
And we have three cookies now
the menu, only three cookies.
But I pride myself
saying that we
have like probably some
of the best cookies.
I love them.
They're very simple.
They're still like soft
and tender in the center,
like a thin brown outside shell.
And we bake them maybe
for like 10, 15 minutes.
And people will come
just for our cookies.
So it's a simple product.
We always talk about
creativity and how
like it's important, because
I love being creative.
I love looking at classic
and reinterpretting
into a more modern way
of, fun way, of eating it.
But I also think that sometime
a good like simple chocolate
chip cookie is always a winner.
ANANT SHUKLA: Yeah.
And kind of along
those same lines,
when you're trying to perfect
that cookie or perfect a Cronut
or perfect a madeleine,
how many times
do you try something and iterate
and change the ingredients
or change the approach before
you decide you know this is it.
DOMINIQUE ANSEL:
There's no rules.
There's no rules at all.
It's just understanding
where you're
trying to get, knowing
the science of it,
and try everything you can
to sometimes break the rules
and break what you know
to make something new.
It's trying.
It's just like hard work.
And it's just a good
stamina to never give up.
Sometimes it takes us a few
days to develop new recipes.
And sometimes it takes us a
few months, like the Cronut.
The Cronut took me
over three months just
to perfect the recipe.
I was not happy with the texture
in the beginning, we changed
the type of flour we used,
the technique, the temperature
of the oil, the
kind of oil we use,
feeling that the glaze
everything has been really
a break down by each part
to make a great dessert
ANANT SHUKLA: Yeah.
And along the same line, you
mentioned science as something,
as part of the approach.
I know you often talk
about time as an ingredient
that people neglect.
Or nowadays there
are so many recipes
that are shortcuts
or semi-homemade,
but time, especially
with the madeleine
or made to order like how did
you decide that you knew this
was an approach that works?
DOMINIQUE ANSEL: Well,
it's very simple.
It's a childhood memory.
Growing up, I will go to
the bakery with my mom
or my grandma like three
to four times a day.
Three to four times a day, and
not because we're that hungry.
But because you
know like in France
you only get fresh bread, fresh
from the oven, like piping hot.
And you don't let it die.
And this notion
of time with food
is something that everyone
is aware now, I think,
more and more.
And we, for instance,
at the bakery
bake miniature madeleines.
They're like small
pillowy cakes,
like flavored with lemon.
They're delicious.
We bake them only to order.
It takes like three
to four minutes.
So I always tell people it's
faster than getting a latte.
So they're fresh from the oven.
And this kind of emotions I
want to give to our customers.
But if you think about
it, it's the same
for pretty much everything.
You know, like people
eat sushi, they
don't want sushi that was
made like 10 hours ago.
You have a sushi chef that
makes a fresh sushi for you,
putting a new plate
in front of you.
You're not going to
let it sit there.
You want to eat it right away.
That's this moment in time
where the food is perfect.
And for this madeleine,
you know like when
you bite into it,
this mini madeleine,
it's like you have this little
puff of steam that comes out.
And we always say that's the
last breath of the madeleine
before it dies.
So we're very, very
passionate about our food.
And I think time is crucial.
So if you guys come to the
bakery, please be patient.
And order the madeleines.
They are one of my
favorite, definitely.
ANANT SHUKLA: And I think the
same holds true for macaroon,
right?
That need to wait
before you really--
DOMINIQUE ANSEL: Yes, actually.
Just the little
opposite with macaroons.
Like Because the
macaroons, which
is a French little cookie,
like two little shells made
with almond with usually
a filling in the center,
it's in every bakery in France.
And this [INAUDIBLE] time, so
time is an ingredient, yes.
Sometimes time has
to be like, it's
crucial to eat
something right away.
But it's also sometimes--
food needs some time to rest.
So with a macaroon, since it's
a little shell of cookie that
is like semi-dry, and when
we put the filling inside,
actually you have to let it sit
for a day or two for the shell
to absorb the humidity
from the filling.
And then you have like a
thin, super thin, crust.
And when you bite
into it, it's tender.
So that's the opposite
of the madeleine.
ANANT SHUKLA: Yeah.
Great.
And so here we have a
picture of the bakery.
We talked a little bit.
You started in 2011.
And you talked about
the conversation
you had with Chef Daniel.
But again, what was that
spark that again you're
taking the second
risk now in New York,
not only of moving
here from France
and now moving from Daniel
to starting your own thing
and becoming a full
blown entrepreneur.
What was that feeling and
process going through your mind
and did you ever have a moment
that you were like, shoot,
I did the wrong thing?
DOMINIQUE ANSEL: Oh, it
happened very, very fast.
I give my notice to Daniel.
And believe me or
not, seven weeks later
I was opening the bakery.
So it happened just like this.
And it's a moment where I didn't
realize how fast I was going
and what was going to happen.
Just keep in mind that this
little bakery on Spring Street,
when I first opened it,
only had four employees.
And it was a little bit
more than five years ago.
Only four employees-- two people
in the kitchen, two people
doing coffee and service.
I will take out
the trash myself I
will like clean
everything myself.
So now we, of
course, we've grown.
But it started as a very,
very like small neighborhood
business, very humble.
I've done the painting there
myself, cleaned the toilet
many times.
I have like electrocuted myself.
I've fixed and cleaned every
square inch of this bakery.
So at the time, it was just--
ANANT SHUKLA: A scrappy,
scrappy startup, right?
Just like here at Google.
DOMINIQUE ANSEL:
Yeah, like let's go.
Exactly, almost like Google.
It was just like,
let's open a shop
and see if we can
please people with it.
And let's just give me a chance
to like to do the kind of food
I like.
In the beginning
it was also tough
because before opening
and right at the opening,
everyone would give me advice,
even I was not asking for it.
Advice on what I should
do, what I shouldn't do.
That was New York City,
a lot of pastry chefs
have failed, a lot of
bakeries have closed,
and that I should do
cupcakes and cheese sticks.
That's all we'll sell.
And should do like tons
of [INAUDIBLE] cheese.
By a fridge and pre-wrap
everything at night
and leave it there
on the counter.
And it was just--
I was exhausted, actually.
Exhausted by listening
to like bad advice.
And especially when you
don't ask for it, right?
So I kind of like
isolated myself
and decided not to listen,
not to listen to anyone.
And just like do things
with my heart and the things
that I believed in,
which is quality
food like always the best
ingredients, creative food
and seasonality.
I was creating new dishes,
used the best ingredients that
are in season, and
customer service,
giving the best to our
customers all the time.
ANANT SHUKLA: Yeah.
And that's true, like
what is it you said?
When you stay true to
your guiding principles,
the bakery instantly became
the highest rated bakery
in the city with all of the
mouthwatering kind of desserts
we saw in the video.
But it's kind of been the
Cronut that obviously took
the world by storm in 2013.
Tell me kind of in your eyes
how that story unfolded.
And why do you think
it took off as it did?
DOMINIQUE ANSEL:
Well, that's a--
ANANT SHUKLA: And
where was the idea?
We talked a little bit that
you'd spent three months trying
to perfect the recipe.
DOMINIQUE ANSEL: Yeah, so
my girl friend, my business
partner, asked me to do
a donut for Mother's Day.
And I was like, ah, you
know, I don't really
have a recipe for donut.
I don't know how
to make a donut.
And she pushes me every day.
And lift me up every day,
of course, to get better.
And I actually made
a donut that was not
with a regular donut dough.
But I made it with something
similar to a croissant,
the same techniques.
And we put it on the
menu ahead of time.
And it was still like a
few of us in the bakery.
We put it on the menu, only
made a few for Mother's Day.
And we had a friend, a
blogger had a camera,
snap a photo on the corner of
the table, put it on this blog.
And he called me the next day.
He was like, hey,
Dominique, I just
want to let you know
my article went viral.
I was like, great,
I'm happy for you.
I'm going back to my kitchen.
I had like two hours of sleep.
And I just want to go
back to my kitchen.
I'm happy for you.
He's like no, no, no.
You don't understand.
I'm going to send
you this chart.
He had to like get a chart off
like the traffic on the web
site and the spike of 300%
within just a few hours.
I was like OK.
Let's go.
Don't know what
to tell you but--
he's like no, no.
You should be ready.
You should make more, do more.
I think we made like
35 the first day.
So I was like OK,
I'll make 45 tomorrow.
[LAUGHTER]
And of course, by the time
by the time we knew it,
which is like two days
later, we had over 150 people
waiting outside.
But still like
four employees, two
in the kitchen and
two barristers.
And I don't remember
what happened.
I just remember that
it was very stressful.
My nights were very, very short.
ANANT SHUKLA: Yeah.
And we saw some of the
craziest stories, the dumpster
divers, all the celebrities
that came and waited in line.
DOMINIQUE ANSEL:
Yes, celebrities.
They wanted to cut in line.
And I made a very,
very strict rule
which I still keep to this day,
that no one cuts this line.
Like no one.
None of my friends,
and I have less now.
None of have my family.
My family visited New York
and they wanted a Cronut,
so I told them to
go wait in line.
And they didn't want to wait,
so they didn't try the Cronut.
Fair for everyone, right?
I had celebrities.
I had like the French
first lady coming.
She didn't get a Cronut either.
So it's not to be--
it is important for me to
be respectful and mindful
of our customers that
come early in the morning.
People were coming
in like 2, 3 o'clock
in the morning when we're
opening at 8:00 at the time.
It's crazy.
They were waiting
for 5 or 6 hours
just outside to get a Cronut.
And I didn't want to be
disrespectful to them.
So I met a strict rule where I
won't let anyone cut the line.
I will kindly ask everyone
to come wait in line.
The line is better now, guys.
You don't to come out at
2 o'clock in the morning.
We still have a line of like
80 to 120 people every morning.
Usually starts, then we
get in around 7 o'clock,
and we open at 8:00.
So it's not as bad
as it used to be.
But still, we should have
long lines for the Cronut.
We limit the quantity
of what we can
do because our kitchen on Spring
Street is very, very small.
It's smaller than this stage.
I'm not exaggerating.
And there's one table.
This is where it all started--
one table, like
three compartment
sink to wash dishes next to it.
And we don't have much.
So I want to make
sure we preserve
the quality and freshness
of the product we serve.
So we can limit ourselves to
a couple hundred every day
to make sure that we can satisfy
people and not overdo it.
And when I decided that I didn't
want our creations to kill
our creativity, and that I will
continue on creating new items
and come up with new ideas,
which is very challenging.
ANANT SHUKLA: Yeah.
And like you said,
you didn't want
to just become known
as the Cronut shop.
And how does the Cronut then
fit in with the other kind
of creations on the menu?
Especially if you know people
are queuing up in the morning.
DOMINIQUE ANSEL:
Yeah, at the time,
you know, like everyone
wanted a Cronut.
And I had more people
coming, give me advice,
telling me that I didn't
understand the business,
and what to do, and I should
get a factory in Long Island
or like New Jersey
and mass produce it.
I was told that I should be
in like every supermarket
to cash out.
And people have tried to
come, and this is not me.
It's just not me.
My dad like spent his whole
life working in the factory.
I will not do that.
This is not who I am.
It's not what I want to do with
our precious little bakery.
And I decided that I will
keep on creating just
to fight the popularity
of the Cronut,
and to show people
that there's more.
There's more that can be done.
So I love the Cronut.
I think it bought us
like a lot of awareness
and showed people that
a pastry can be creative
and a pastry chef
can be creative.
But that's not it.
We've created hundreds and
hundreds of new pastries
since then.
And still to this
day, we'll keep
on creating from our
shop in Tokyo, London,
and soon in Los Angeles.
Every single location, I'll
keep on pushing for creativity.
ANANT SHUKLA: Yeah.
And you get that recognition.
When the first
lady came, I think
the president called you to
chat with you on the cell phone.
DOMINIQUE ANSEL: Actually,
she was texting him,
and he called her.
And actually handed
the phone to me.
And she was like,
this is for you.
And I was like, excuse
me, should I get this?
It's for you.
It's Mr. President.
And I was like, oh, OK.
And I pick up the phone.
It was a little scary because he
knew everything about my life.
He knew that my siblings, where
I grew up, what I was doing,
maybe my tax I was paying.
I don't know.
But I don't know.
Maybe he had run a
background check.
But he was very
pleased to talk to me
and told me that he was very
proud of what I was doing here.
He also told me that
the Cronut was French.
And when I corrected
him, I was, it's
half French, half American.
He was like no, no, it's French.
OK.
If it was Obama, I would
say something else.
ANANT SHUKLA:
Yeah, you mentioned
your other kind of creations.
This is the DKA, right?
This is actually, I believe,
the most popular, right?
DOMINIQUE ANSEL: So the
DKA is our best seller
across like every
cities, every countries.
And it's actually my favorite.
I tell people I eat
one every morning.
They don't believe me.
I really do.
I love it.
It's essentially almost like
a flaky caramelized croissant,
with like a nice crunchy
shell on the outside.
You guys have all had it?
And like this gooey, soft,
and tender center, I love it.
I'll eat it night and day.
It's actually
something I introduced
when I was at Daniel.
We always weekly meeting.
I will always challenge
my team to come up
with something new
or something classic
that I wanted them
to see the technique.
And it's something I had done
back in front a little bit.
So I wanted to make a newer,
lighter version of it.
I brought it to the
manager meeting at Daniel.
And they all went crazy for it.
They are asking
for it every week.
I was like no, no, no.
This is off the menu.
It's just for the meeting.
I'm not putting
this on the menu.
And they're all asking for this.
So I decided to put it on
the menu on Spring Street,
and the bakery.
And people love it.
We actually call it the DKA
so it's simpler to pronounce.
It stands for
Dominique's Kouign Amann.
And kouign amann means
buttery cake in Celtic.
It's from Brittany.
ANANT SHUKLA: The next one also
has a very interesting story.
And this, the cookie
shot wasn't meant--
DOMINIQUE ANSEL: It was
meant to be so popular.
The cookie shot actually
started at South By Southwest.
Yeah I was called
with a PR company
to collaborate, to
do something new.
So it's a show that promotes
innovation and creativity,
technology.
I was asked to come and then
to do something with them.
So they told me a story
of their PR company
and how this started.
It started late
at night at a bar,
where they were like writing
ideas on napkin and drinking
shot.
And I was like, oh, that's cool.
So I'll do something for you.
So we at the time like
created this cookie shot.
And we set up a bar.
We had different kind of milk.
And it was like a fun event.
And it turned in to
be like very popular.
We did it just for one night.
We had a few hundred that night.
And we had a line of over 700
people waiting just for this.
And this was meant
just for this event.
So I was going back to
New York a day later,
and before I even got back,
everyone was asking for it.
We decided to put
it on the menu.
It's been one of our best
sellers now since then.
We offer it in the afternoon.
It's an afternoon snack,
of course, cookie and milk.
From 3 PM until closing.
And in Tokyo as well, like it
was one of our best sellers.
So it's been very popular.
ANANT SHUKLA: And you perfected
the cookie on the way there.
DOMINIQUE ANSEL: So
it's served warm.
We pour fresh farm
milk that infused
with vanilla inside, a nice ice
cold milk and a warm cookie.
And people always ask
me how should I eat it.
Just get a shot
and eat the cookie.
It's very fun.
ANANT SHUKLA: This we talked
about, the frozen s'more.
DOMINIQUE ANSEL: Yeah,
the frozen s'more.
So it's beautiful like crunchy
shell and you can see this
like tender marshmallow,
the vanilla ice cream.
ANANT SHUKLA: So you
mentioned you've started
to expand globally now--
two stores in Tokyo,
a bakery in London,
you're working towards your
first restaurant in LA.
How do you expand the
brand when you can only
be physically in one
location at any time,
and stay authentic to
that kind of mission,
and pushing the boundary.
DOMINIQUE ANSEL: Yeah, I
will say just two things--
talent and technology.
Talent, because I
need good chefs,
strong chefs that have the
same vision, or at least
can learn how to create,
how to think out of the box.
And we have a lot of talented
chefs in London, in Tokyo.
ANANT SHUKLA: A lot of the
team is here today with you,
as well.
DOMINIQUE ANSEL:
My team is here.
We have our chef
from [INAUDIBLE],,
our chef for the
restaurant in LA as well.
I'm very fortunate that the
team is everything for me.
I mean, without a team, there's
no good leader without a team.
And I think it's important to
challenge the team every day.
But also to support them
into everything they do.
And technology-- technology
is very important.
I have my cell phone with me
all day, like everyone now.
And there's lots of
apps to get into a call,
send videos, and see photos.
So I stay connected
with our team
in London, Tokyo, every
day, every single day
without exception.
ANANT SHUKLA: And the menu
is custom at each location.
Think this is, again,
the Tokyo bakery.
How have you adapted the local
flavors to suit local taste?
I think this is an example of
the creme de la corn, which
probably in the US it's not
the taste and flavor profile
that most people would expect.
But--
DOMINIQUE ANSEL: I don't know.
I think corn is
very popular here.
We're actually going to
launch this very soon just
for weekend at the kitchen.
So in Tokyo, we started
with kind of the New York
menu, which was 70%.
And we created like a small
menu just to test and see.
And now it has that flipped.
Like about 80% of the
menu is local creations.
And about 20% is the
signature from New York.
And why?
Because I think you
know before anything
a bakery is a local business.
So you have to cater to
your local customers.
And the culture is
different, so you
have to use local ingredients
like local produce,
but also like celebrate every
local holiday and tradition
as well.
ANANT SHUKLA: And
this is also one.
That is the zero gravity, which
is inside of a balloon, right?
DOMINIQUE ANSEL: Yes.
So it's a light, super
light, fluffy chiffon
cake inside a balloon.
It's our zero gravity cake.
So that's how we call it.
It's for a new shop
in Ginza, in Japan.
Then we ask people to tale a
little pin and pop the balloon.
So sometimes we put confetti
inside for birthdays.
People love it.
It's very fun.
ANANT SHUKLA: Then this is
the kitchen here right here,
opened April 2015.
It was your second store
opening in New York.
How did you decide that
it was the right time?
DOMINIQUE ANSEL: So
everyone was asking me
from the time when I launched
the Cronut until we opened
the kitchen, everyone
was asking what
is the next, what is
the next pastry, what
is the next hybrid
you're going to create.
And I always told people, it's
not about creating hybrid.
It's about being creative.
The Cronut might be known
for being a hybrid pastry,
but it's not about this,
really, but creating
emotions and new things.
So when everyone was expecting
the next hybrid pastry,
I give them the next
hybrid bakery, which
is Dominique Ansel Kitchen.
So we take time
as an ingredient.
And we make everything
freshly made to order.
Why?
Because it's something
I've done my entire life,
working in the kitchen,
mixing a chocolate mousse
and taking a spoon of it.
And I realized that
the best moment in time
were the food was that good
is when you are making it.
So if you come to
Dominique Ansel Kitchen,
we have a large
portion of our menu
that we make to order, like this
very light, fluffy chocolate
mousse.
We have a lemon
[INAUDIBLE] tart where
we use [INAUDIBLE]
actually where
we mix the butter and the curd,
and we emulsify it to order.
And we have a super
thin tart shell,
and we're pour this creamy,
creamy, buttery lemon curd
into the tart shell.
So it's like, you have
this beautiful textures,
and it's super delicate.
And it says different emotions,
different way of eating food.
ANANT SHUKLA: Yeah.
And these are the matcha--
DOMINIQUE ANSEL: These
are the matcha beignets.
So they are fried to order.
And they're little
puffy fluffy beignet
dough with the little
bit of lime zest,
and we finish it with tons
of matcha powdered sugar.
ANANT SHUKLA: Yeah, and another
kind of unique opportunity
that I'm not sure
if everybody knows
is kind of up, that you run kind
of after hours at the kitchen.
DOMINIQUE ANSEL: Yes.
I love-- I always tell
people pastry chefs,
especially in restaurants,
they're always--
they don't really
have the story to tell
because when you have dinner,
whatever savory food the chef
cooks, you have to
follow with a dessert.
So if the chef cooks
like classic food,
you have to do classic desserts.
And if it's super modern,
you have to be super modern.
So this is an opportunity for
us to be close to our customers.
So this is our kitchen
in the West Village.
And here we have a table
that's hanged on the ceiling.
So UP stands for
Unlimited Possibilities.
And this is where we
serve our testing menu.
We were working on the next one.
It's going to be very
fun for the fall.
And we're right here in the
middle of the kitchen, where
we prep the food for you.
We turn around and we drop it.
And we can tell you the story
from actually beginning to end.
ANANT SHUKLA: Yeah.
I think one of the
interesting ones,
I think, the tech boom, right?
DOMINIQUE ANSEL: Yes.
The first few minutes were
eight courses of only desserts.
And it's not too much.
They're small-- small portions.
And this one was the tech boom.
So it's essentially
one of the first Mac.
And so I work with an engineer
to create this little computer
where we give
people a flash disk.
And when you put the flash
disk in the computer,
it shoots out waffles.
So it shoots out warm waffles.
And it's a way of
experiencing UP
and to have like little stories
behind every of the dishes.
ANANT SHUKLA: I think
one more we have here.
First heartbreak, right?
DOMINIQUE ANSEL: Yes.
This is another dish that
we created for this menu,
was the first heartbreak.
So the menu was called first.
And it was retracing every
first time of someone's life.
So from the first word to the
first time living on your own,
the first heartbreak
which is right here.
So I got inspired by
love, it start off
with something beautiful,
like this beautiful flower.
And we have a little rice paper
sticking out with a love note.
And we are asking people to
take matches, light the rice
paper on fire, and this
is actually baked Alaska.
So the entire dish will
like catch on fire.
And in the center, you can see
this little chocolate sphere.
And inside was rocky
road ice cream.
So you have your little
ice cream at the end.
It was a very fun way
of telling a story
from beginning to end for us.
ANANT SHUKLA: Great.
We're going to open
up to audience Q&A,
if people want to start lining
up at the mic, on both side.
Kind of the last two
questions I have for you is,
we've talked a little bit
about upcoming projects,
obviously in LA.
Kind of what is next for you?
And where do you see
yourself the next five years?
DOMINIQUE ANSEL: Well,
what's next for me,
I think it's important to
take it one step at a time.
I'm really excited about LA.
We're opening a bakery
there, but we're also
opening our first restaurant--
our first full service seated
restaurant.
So I'm really
excited about this.
I was trained as a chef, as
well [INAUDIBLE] I love cooking.
I've always loved cooking.
Always been in the kitchen,
service side at Daniel's
to see what they were doing,
how they were cooking.
And it is a big step for us.
It's also an
opportunity to showcase
how creative we can be, not
only with desserts but also
with like savory food.
ANANT SHUKLA: Yeah.
And then especially
at Google, we
have kind of my last question
is, people always ask us,
we have so much
free food around,
how are you not
putting on weight?
When you're in the kitchen
with all these desserts,
what is your secret to not?
DOMINIQUE ANSEL:
There's no secret.
You sleep very little.
And you're standing
on your feet all day
long, going up and down.
So I eat a lot,
taste a lot of food.
It's just a matter of like--
I don't know, maybe
I'm lucky too.
ANANT SHUKLA: Fast metabolism.
DOMINIQUE ANSEL: Yeah,
maybe fast metabolism.
ANANT SHUKLA: Great.
We can start.
AUDIENCE: Hi Dominique.
My name is Claire.
Amazing inspiration
on all your sweet
treats, which I
think we all love.
Switching to savory, what
savory foods do you like to eat?
And do you have favorite
restaurants in New York?
DOMINIQUE ANSEL: What savory
food do I like to eat?
I'm very curious, so
I love exploring food.
I force myself-- even though
I don't have too much time--
force myself to go out, to
see every new restaurant.
I love eclectic cuisine.
I love seeing different flavors,
different styles of cooking.
Some of my favorite
restaurants--
I have a lot.
I have a long list.
Blue Hill is one of them.
I am actually doing
a chef collaboration
with Dan Barber today and this
weekend at the other kitchen.
And we're doing this
beautiful scotch egg.
So, Dan Barber, which is--
I don't know if you
guys know about him--
one of the best chefs in
the country, has a farm
Blue Hill Stone Farm upstate.
And he has found a way to feed
this chicken with red pepper
and the yolk actually turns red.
So we are doing a
fun like scotch egg,
like beets and these like
beautiful eggs from the farm,
baby corn that is grilled.
And I love Dan Barber's food.
AUDIENCE: Bonjour,
Dominique, Alexander.
Thank you so much
for being here.
I have two questions for you.
One, as a French man who
moved to New York recently,
is a basic survival question.
What do you think is the
best baguette in New York?
DOMINIQUE ANSEL: Ha,
the best baguette.
It's tough.
AUDIENCE: I know.
That's why I'm asking.
DOMINIQUE ANSEL: I love the
baguette at Maison Kayser,
actually.
Yeah, they do a
good job with bread.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
Thank you.
The second question is, so
you're supernational now.
You have multiple locations
in the US, Japan, London.
Are you thinking of
opening shop in Paris?
And I guess in general,
what's your relationship back
to France?
DOMINIQUE ANSEL: I
mean, Paris is my--
I have to say-- like I
love, love, love New York.
Paris is to me one of the most
beautiful cities in the world.
I love, love, love Paris.
I will always love Paris.
I will love eventually
someday getting back
home and doing something there.
I have no plan for now.
But eventually I
would love to go back.
I spent so many years
of my life there.
AUDIENCE: Merci.
DOMINIQUE ANSEL: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
How are you doing?
DOMINIQUE ANSEL: I'm good.
How are you?
AUDIENCE: Oh, it's good.
When you are thinking about
opening a second location,
what made you choose Tokyo
out of all the locations,
basically, in the world?
DOMINIQUE ANSEL:
Our second location
was actually the West Village.
But our second
internationally was Tokyo.
You're right.
And Tokyo was just--
it was just a matter of like
market, this huge market
for bakeries there.
People are crazy about
bakeries, about pastries,
about food in general.
The market is actually
quite saturated.
And there's so many
bakeries everywhere.
They love and
understand French food.
And we met some good people that
help us developing the business
there, and opening to business.
So that was natural
like next step for me.
Tokyo is a market that I love.
Every time I go back there's
so much to see and culturally
to learn about.
There's like excellent
food everywhere.
Even the smallest
little shop like
will make the best food ever.
So it was a natural next
step for me to go to Japan.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DOMINIQUE ANSEL: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
DOMINIQUE ANSEL: Hi.
AUDIENCE: I was curious.
It sounded like you had
a whole bunch of recipes
that you started to build
when you arrived at the United
States.
Are there any
ingredients or techniques
that you discovered as well?
DOMINIQUE ANSEL: Well, tons.
Yes.
I think it's an industry where--
food industry is
an industry where
you learn beginning
with recipes from chef,
and then you, if
you're smart enough,
should build from there.
Always look at the recipes why
they were done a certain way.
There are still
recipes that I use
that two, three
generations ago were using.
But I always like look at
it and try to understand it.
For instance, like butter cream
that we're doing 30 years ago,
had lots more butter,
lots more sugar than now.
And it was used just
as preservative.
Like they were not putting--
they were not having the
refrigeration we have now,
leaving the food outside.
But you know, time is changing.
People are more like
health conscious.
And it's important to
always look at the recipe,
like tweak them, perfect them.
And there's like
always tons of recipes
and new ideas we're developing.
For instance, right now, between
all of our locations from Tokyo
to New York and London
there's probably like 50,
60 different menu items
that are being developed.
So it's perpetual.
We never stop thinking of
new techniques, new recipes.
We're constantly developing.
It's a part of the process,
part of what we do.
AUDIENCE: Have you done
anything with kale?
DOMINIQUE ANSEL: I
actually was asked
to do something with kale.
AUDIENCE: Don't do it.
DOMINIQUE ANSEL:
It was not too bad.
I did a kale sorbet.
It was very light.
AUDIENCE: Dominique,
have you ever
tried experimenting
with using something
in place of egg in recipes?
And if you have, have found
anything that works well?
DOMINIQUE ANSEL: I mean, I have
not played too much with eggs.
But I know people use
different source of protein
to emulsify mixes.
I know there's a lot
of things out there.
Not too much, I haven't played
too much with egg whites.
But I sometimes get asked
a question [INAUDIBLE]..
ANANT SHUKLA: Great.
Well, let's give Chef Dominique
a big round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
ANANT SHUKLA: Thank
you for joining us.
DOMINIQUE ANSEL: Thank you.
Thank you, everyone.